avec la sécheresse le risque de feu de
forêt s'accentue près de 500 hectares de
végétation ont brûlé dans le
Loir-et-Cher en 2022 il suffit d'une
étincelle pour que les broussailles
s'enflamment alors les pompiers du 10 41
c'est qui depuis quelques années et se
forme dès à présent à combattre les feux
de forêt clémence d'eauck et Hélène
chapelet ont suivi un groupe de
stagiaires en plein exercices dans la
forêt de Boulogne près de Blois
là l'unité feu de forêt est engagée sur
une mise en situation cet après-midi un
départ de feu en forêt de Boulogne sur
la commune de Mont-près-Chambord où on
va faire manœuvrer deux camions-citerne
feux de forêt de Lens qui vont être mis
en action par les stagiaires pour sa
guérir aux techniques feux de forêt
depuis le début de la semaine 28
sapeurs-pompiers professionnels ou
volontaires après n'a intervenir sur les
feux de forêt si les femmes sont ici
fictives la connaissance du milieu est
primordial tous les arbres ne brûlent
pas de la même manière si on arrive dans
des forêts de résineux qui ont une base
de calorifique qui sont très importantes
dues à leur résine tout de suite on sait
qu'on est face à des arbres qui sont
potentiellement plus actifs et beaucoup
plus forts qu'une qu'un chaîne qui lui
potentiellement reste toujours un
minimum humide et on n'a pas le même
pouvoir calorifique et la même vitesse
de propagation pour économiser l'eau
potable les pompiers disposent de
nouveaux à l'image de cette pompe
flottante motorisée relié à une bâche
elle permet de constituer une réserve à
partir d'un plan d'eau les innovations
techniques concernent aussi les
camions-citerne feux de forêt ils
peuvent faire face à des situations
compliquées comme l'encerclement par les
flammes on peut voir ici un dispositif
d'autoprotection qui permet de faire une
bulle de sécurité autour de la cabine de
mettre en sécurité notre équipage de
quatre personnes des masques qu'on
trouve en partie supérieure pour que
tout le monde puisse venir respirer le
temps que le feu puisse passer sur les
véhicules en cas d'événement très
défavorable pour les équipes qui sont au
contact du feu les procédures et les
véhicules sont normalisés dans tous les
10 de France car les feux de végétation
ne sont plus un phénomène propre au sud
du pays je suis sapeur-pompier
volontaire depuis 1994 donc j'ai eu à
traiter plusieurs plusieurs feux de
forêt des feux de forêt qui évoluent
depuis de nombreuses années au regard
des phénomènes par exemple climatiques
des feux importants récemment notamment
aussi sur le sur le Loir-et-Cher à
prunier en Sologne feu de grande ampleur
la formation est dispensée juste avant
l'été période où le risque d'incendie
augmente en 2022 dans le Loir-et-Cher 90
hectares de forêts sont partis en fumée